[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
honoring the life of supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg
a system of justice will be the richer
for diversity of background and
experience
and former that 70s show star danny
masterson
appears in court on rape charges his
defense
lashes back also eight people killed in
rural ohio
the case against one of the defendants
accused of playing a role in a massacre
plus the state tries to stop a judge
from dismissing the case against one of
the cops
accused of murdering george floyd law
and crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
we begin with reaction to the death of
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
a black cloth draping the seat on the
nation's high court
which ginsburg occupied for 27 years
the practice of mourning injustice in
such a fashion dates back to at least
1873. the late justice was a champion of
women's rights and an advocate for
gender equality
she attended columbia law school was a
professor at
rutgers law and served as an attorney
for the american civil liberties union
president bill clinton appointed her to
serve on the supreme court in 1993
after she sat on the d.c district court
of appeals for the third for 13 years
prior to that
she was the second woman to serve as a
supreme court justice and her words at
her nomination reflected her hope that
her achievements
would pave the way for others in my
lifetime
i expect there will be among federal
judicial nominees
based on the excellence of their
qualifications
as many sisters as brothers in law
that prospect
that prospect is indeed cause for hope
and its realization will be cause for
celebration
terry austin your thoughts on justice
ginsburg how are you remembering her
well you know i have a very special
place in my heart for her she is
actually the picture on my facebook and
has been
for years and the reason is she did
so much for women in terms of equality
her point was
don't put us on a pedestal because
that's not treating us
equally it's unfair to do that and she
started her career
very early making sure she picked and
selected cases
that you know really made a difference
as far as that's concerned
and i was very fortunate enough to have
the opportunity to sit in on her class
when i was at columbia
and i got another professor for a
constitutional law but
all of us would try to you know squeeze
into her classroom because even back in
the 80s
she was someone who was much of a legend
back then
just someone you wanted to see sit in on
the master class brian
reaction from the conservative wing of
the court here clarence thomas saying
that she was the essence of grace
civility and dignity
called her unfailingly gracious and said
he will
dearly miss his friend samuel alito
saying
she'll go down as a leading figure in
the history of the court brett
kavanaugh even saying that he keeps and
will continue to keep a picture of her
in his office so people respected her a
great deal even if they disagreed with
her legally
she was greatly respected because while
many people were playing checkers she
was playing legal chess i mean i would
encourage people to go back
and not just look at her as a justice of
the supreme court but also look at the
work she did in the aclu
look at frontiero v richardson
weinerberger
weinsfield um usb virginia auburnfield
hodges
she laid the groundwork for so many
people and talking as a person who
their rights can be connected to so many
other u.s supreme court cases my ability
to love my wife my ability to be more
than three-fifths a person
i tip my hat to this woman because she
did so much for so many
we remember her through her
jurisprudence and if you haven't read it
it is certainly worth reading
an actor best known for his role in that
70s show appeared in court for the first
time to face rape charges
in a case associated with the metoo
movement danny masterson is accused of
raping three women in his home between
2001
and 2003. the women came forward three
years ago but masterson was just
arrested three months ago
masterson is out on more than three
million dollars bond his attorney
insists he's innocent
here the judge explains masterson's
rights an important part of
any first appearance your attorneys may
appear
in court on your behalf with the
president yes sir
do you also understand that you must be
present anytime the court orders you to
be president
for any substantive hearing for any
preliminary hearing
for any trial and for any disposition in
this matter
yes sir mr masterson your attorneys have
filed a demure in this case
i just said a briefing schedule that
demurrer will be litigated
very likely at the next court date do
you understand that you have the
absolute right to be present
at that hearing and give up that right
and agree that your attorney can appear
on your behalf
yes sir masterson's attorneys asked the
judge for a protective order to prevent
information about the case from being
released to the public
prosecutors agreed with the concept but
said the motion
was just too broad
this protective order as it's currently
drafted
as it's constructed is objectionable
first of all it's over broad it's
grossly overbroad and i think it asks
this court
to exercise jurisdiction over over
parties
third parties that is beyond
the scope it needs to be more narrowly
tailored
i think as it's written as grossly
overbought and again i think also
premature
since council has not yet reviewed the
evidence they don't know
what uh it's contained and what their
order is asking to
to limit in terms of the disclosure that
defense motion denied
victims filed civil suits against the
actor and against the church of
scientology last year
local reporter carrie entholus explains
what's behind those
related civil cases
victims have come forward um and i
i believe three of them are included in
the criminal indictment
but four victims have alleged that
the church of scientology and mr
masterson
covered up and tried to
to intimidate bully assault
these victims in in a civil case that
was filed last year
and included in those allegations are
that
a dog was poisoned one of the victim's
dogs was poisoned
um and so the intimidation tactics
are part of this or the alleged
intimidation tax
tactics are part of a civil suit that's
going on in los angeles civil court
right now
let's jump in with some analysis right
now brian buckmeyer let's talk about
this case because procedurally the
posture is interesting here we've got
accusations going back 17
19 years is there a benefit to
prosecuting a case that old or is there
a drawback
there's definitely a drawback i mean
some people can't remember what they had
for breakfast yesterday but
as time goes on your memory decreases
and it becomes that much easier for a
defense attorney to poke holes in that
however we've seen the way be paved in
the harvey weinstein trial and the bill
cosby trial
and that might not be as difficult as it
was in years past so terry when we look
at the law here
usually a statute of limitations is in
play in place i should say as well
to prevent a prosecution against
accusations this old but
as we've seen with many sex related
crimes oftentimes legislatures are
opening up that statute of limitations
well that's exactly right you know in
california right now under the penal
code
it's a 10-year statute of limitations
with some exception so for instance if
the victim was
under 18 years of old but we're seeing
that that's
looking to be expanded just because of
the cases that brian just mentioned
the bill cosby case et cetera and i
think legislators and
individuals in general are looking to
extend the time so people
can bring these charges because it's
difficult to bring them initially
and we're seeing an example of that
right now terry so what's your thought
in this better or
worse for a prosecutor to try to go
after a case like this
well i think it's going to be more
difficult for the prosecutor the more
time you have
obviously the less evidence you're going
to have certainly terry austin
and still ahead on law and crime daily
officials in louisville kentucky are
bracing for what could be an imminent
imminent decision rather involving the
police officers who killed brianna
taylor
and one of the many defendants accused
in a killing spree involving a custody
dispute
is back in court that another reports
when law on crime daily continues
[Music]
welcome back everybody two federal
buildings in louisville kentucky are
closed this week over a big decision
from local authorities
sources tell local tv stations there
that a decision on whether to criminally
charge three police officers
over the killing of brianna taylor is
expected to come
this week the federal courthouse is
closed and boarded up
in case protests break out all scheduled
hearings there have been pushed back
or will be done by video conference the
decision on whether to file charges
rests in the hands of the kentucky
attorney general the ag's office has
refused to provide a timeline on when an
announcement might occur
taylor was shot and killed of course
during a no-knock raid
on her appoint on her apartment rather
conducted by plainclothes
officers the case against one of the key
defendants in ohio's so-called pike
county massacre
is slowly moving along jacob wagner his
brother george and their parents are
charged with murdering eight people in
2016 but charges
were dropped against grandmother
frederica wagner authorities say members
of the rhoden
family were killed over a custody
dispute involving a young child jacob
wagner shared with hannah rhoden
wagner's attorneys filed several motions
in the case a full hearing has been
delayed until next month
defense was taking the position that it
would seem to us for example that
just as an example statements attributed
to angela wagner regarding certain set
of shoes
seem to be fundamentally admissible if
and only if the court ruled the state's
favor
as statements of co-conspirators
and council wilson mentioned that may
not be the only way that's
that statements and perhaps others like
it may
have a pathway to admissibility for the
prosecution
a long-winded way is saying is there may
be more fighting and writing to be done
as we progress on these particulars
it appears the trial could come down to
a battle of the experts
one of the big questions is how forensic
analysts are interpreting bloody shoe
prints
found at the crime scene the majority of
stuff has been
provided to them we provided them all
the bench notes for all of our expert
reports
from the bureau of criminal
investigations however we
in the most recent discovery dump we
gave them
two new reports that dude we did not
give them bench notes for but they're
now requesting those
and then we did not have bench notes for
dr bodziak
so we will attempt to get those
okay let's jump in now this was supposed
to be a big two-day long hearing
terry and now we've got word that
they're trying to shut things down
because one of the attorneys might want
to retire
and things like that so when you've got
this many defendants
and this drawn out of a proceeding
doesn't the judge want to get in here
and say let's move this thing along
i would think so aaron because this case
took place i remember when it happened
now in 2016 that's a long time ago it's
four years now
and when you have a case of this
magnitude where an entire family eight
members
were killed that's something you don't
want to delay so
i would think that the judge would tell
the attorneys look you better get moving
here
we've got to get started even with covet
19 we still have to make sure
that justice is served here because this
was brutal and brian what's going on
with the arrest of the grandmother then
that case ultimately gets dropped here
so
do prosecutors have their act together
on this one or not
nine times out of ten the answer is
usually no but this is a complicated
case there's a lot of moving pieces i
mean even as i'm reading it
you've got so many defendants so many
victims the ballistics i mean the
defense attorneys i'm assuming are going
to be jumping up and down
screaming fry hearing fry hearing which
is the standard by which you can
scientifically
assess things like the ballistics report
or the shoe print evidence so there's a
lot of moving pieces here i wouldn't lay
it at the feet of any one group of
people
judge defense attorney prosecutor i
think it's just a difficult case to
prosecute and of course terry a
collision between the rights of the
various defendants as well
oftentimes in a situation like this well
that's right i mean they're sitting
waiting for trial so their rights are
not being abided by right now at that
point too exactly
got to make sure everybody gets a fair
trial and later on the broadcast here
the strange legal argument being made by
attorneys representing a mother accused
of playing a role in the deaths
of her children but first minnesota
prosecutors are trying to stop
a judge from throwing the murder case
against ex-cop derrick chauvin
out of court we break down their
arguments next
on law and crime daily
minnesota prosecutors are fighting back
and against an attempt by derek chovin
to have the charges against him thrown
out of court
chauvin of course was the former
minneapolis police officer
who pressed his knee into george floyd's
neck ultimately
murdering him according to prosecutors
they say chauvin ignored training
materials requiring
suspects to be placed on their sides to
recover after a so-called
maximum restraint technique is used
that's a similar technique to what
chauvin was caught on video doing to
floyd but not exactly the same
training materials also required chauvin
to call medics after using a choke hold
similar to what he actually did do to
floyd
training materials further required
chauvin to directly
render medical aid rather than merely
wait for medics to arrive
prosecutors wrote the officers held
floyd for approximately nine minutes
about five
times longer than the national anthem
and four times longer than president
lincoln's gettysburg address
during that time chauvin continued to
kneel on floyd's neck for about four
minutes
after lane told the other officers that
floyd was passing out
and for two and a half minutes after
king said floyd did not have a pulse
indeed he continued to press his knee
into floyd's neck for a full minute
after emergency medical personnel
arrived on the scene and even while
emergency personnel
tried to check floyd's pulse so
some interesting literary arguments
there brian let's back up and look at
the procedure here chauvin is saying the
case should be dismissed because
of a lack of probable cause that
basically means an ordinary person
would have a quote honest and strong
suspicion that a suspect is
guilty of a crime is it easy or hard to
get a case tossed at this point in the
proceeding
well as a defense attorney it's
remarkably hard the standard is
very very difficult even before you get
to that errand you have to realize that
all the facts are in the light most
favorable to that of the prosecution so
even then if you're arguing between uh
how a fact can be interpreted both ways
the prosecution wins on that one so it's
very difficult for the defense
prosecution gets the benefit
of the doubt so terry on the merits here
this looks like the state is turning
this into a miniature trial
about training is that a strong or a
weak
way to build this case knowing what we
know now
well i'll give you a legal answer it
depends you know
it could backfire on the prosecutors
they could demonstrate that the the
police department had sufficient
policies and procedures
and that the officers failed to follow
those policies and procedures
so yeah certainly that's where they're
going with things terry um
and and what i'm trying to figure out
here is we've got all this literary
flowering language about the gettysburg
address about the national anthem it
sounds good
but does it take the eye off the ball
here because the bottom line is the
state's trying to prove
uh a degree of murder here not whether
or not he complied with a training
standard
exactly and and that's where i think it
could backfire on them so if the jury
thinks
well the police did all that they could
they followed all of the policies and
procedures
and there was nothing more that the
officer himself could do
then i think that it could backfire on
the prosecution and
showing these policies and procedures
and focusing on that
might really help the jury to come to a
conclusion that the police did nothing
wrong here
i get very nervous when we focus on
training because training procedures are
not the actual
law being applied in a case and brian
you're shaking your head
i don't think baby you cross-examine a
police officer and this is what they
want to do they want to uphold their
training manual and say
i do this i'm such a great officer i do
this all the time but if you can lock an
officer into the fact
that their training manual says one
thing and they did the opposite their
bible their testament
it is a strong way to dismantle that the
officer knew
it was wrong and did it anyways i think
it works pretty well taking the
prosecution side brian buckmeyer
when we return when we return the
so-called doomsday cult mom makes a
legal request for her upcoming trial
that some defense attorneys
find surprising we'll unravel that
mystery right after this
[Music]
and now to a rather interesting decision
by defendant lori valo and her upcoming
trial on charges related to the
disappearance and deaths of her children
velo and her husband chad daybell are
charged with conspiring to alter conceal
or destroy evidence the prosecutor wants
to try both defendants at once and
valo's attorneys are saying in court
papers that they are not
opposed to that plan dabel however is
adamant that the trial
should remain separate in order to
remain fair that's the husband's
argument
it's an odd departure for the wife
however from what we might usually see
in cases where two defendants are
accused of committing the same crime
at the same time the cases are scheduled
to go to trial next year
the state's key witness is a former
friend of lori and chad daybell
who created her own secret recording of
the defendants
but at a pre-trial hearing dave bell's
defense pointed out
that she might have had the incentive to
lie
at some point there was a question
regarding the whereabouts of
jj is that right correct and at that
point you would
advised him that you had had jj in your
care
correct i told him that i had him and
then i didn't have him
okay so the initial time that he told
him that you had jj that was not a
truthful statement
to officer pillar was it correct and
when you tell a statement that's
that's not accurate to a police officer
that's that's a lie
is it not correct so you lied to a
police officer is that correct
correct and then at some point how long
between the time when you
told that lie to the police officer
regarding the whereabouts of j.j valo
did you correct your lie how much time
passed
till i spoke to him on december
6 i believe i could be off a day or two
so approximately 10 to 12 days passed
from the time you told your first lie
to when you decided to come up with a
different story for officer gilbert
later on correct
correct okay let's set the lie aside and
talk about the tactics here terry i'm
used to prosecutors saying
yes let's combine all the trials
together i'm not used to defense
attorneys saying
oh yeah let's go along with that plan is
that a good idea
no that's not a good idea i mean what
her attorney should be doing
is defending the case for her instead of
making sure that they look good in court
one of the motions they made
was that she could wear street clothes
and then they agreed with the
prosecution that the cases should be
brought together so
that's not a good defense for lori but
chad
is making good defenses he is saying
let's keep the cases separate and he
doesn't want to be
involved and he's saying or he could be
saying
look i had nothing to do with this it
just so happened these babies were
buried in my backyard
okay so brian i know you probably agree
with the tactical decision to keep the
trial separate but can we look into this
and say
is somebody getting ready to point the
finger at the other one by having the
other person present in court
i mean yes but that's a very dangerous
move to make you've got to either be
really confident in your defense and
that of the other defendant sitting next
to you because
they're going to point the fingers at
each other but when the jury sees red
for one that means they may see red for
both
and that could definitely affect your
client if you're the one trying to point
the finger
very dangerous brian and terry great
analysis here on law on crime daily and
we will see you next time thanks for
joining us for our discussions about
justice in america
[Music]
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
you